back Chef Carla Pellegrino has been
involved in restaurants from coast to
coast and now she's a partner at
limoncello fresh Italian Kitchen and
they have something very special planned
for Valentine's Day first off welcome
back to our kitchen oh thank you so much
for having me JC I'm very happy to be
here and uh happy to invite you for
Valentine's Day we're excited about
Valentine's Day I'm excited that you
have your hands in another restaurant so
tell us a little about about limoncello
tell us about the restaurant uh
limoncello has been here for about three
years and uh they are like a couple
owners you have Joseph Barbara his wife
Jenny Kim he has been inviting me to go
come back to Vegas and be his partner
for a while and at the beginning now I
think it was the right time it was good
I miss Vegas always try to we bring you
back in so you're back in this
restaurant
back in Italian restaurant okay
Valentine's Day specials what are some
of the specials you guys have and what
are you going to make for us today I'm
going to make today I'm gonna do a salad
because he said he's simply it is fast
for you guys but I did bring my my
risotto my Lobster risotto that's going
to be there exclusively for Valentine's
Day it is delicious we do the with the
classic American sauce and the lobster
tails lobster claws as you see there it
is beautiful it's a little bit long for
the segment so I will make a little pear
salad that we which is going to be you
know okay why don't you start assembling
yes and by the way that the lot that's a
meaty meaty Lobster plate right there
there's a lot of fish right there oh
yeah you have a lot lots of mid diners
we have a lobster claws cognac we have a
little bit of a cognac you know which is
not going to be the alcohol is not going
to be really there you know this it is
just and what are you putting in the
salad is that arugula arugula uh Belgium
Belgium and Dives and then we have some
fresh pears that we're gonna mix I like
it with pears okay yeah so we give that
sweetness which is delicious and as
you're assembling here reservations
required we're recommended for
Valentine's Day yeah we can always do a
reservation on Open Table okay all
through a phone number you know which is
seven jump online yeah online yeah you
can do that Google you know you're gonna
know you know lemon cello fresh Italian
Kitchen we're there and we're gonna be
we have extended hours for Valentine's
Day oh good good it's on West Sahara too
up there in The Lakes it's a beautiful
area beautiful part of town and the fact
that Chef Carla you're involved in this
restaurant now if I'm going out on
Valentine's Day I want to come see you I
know you're gonna have the best food in
Las Vegas it's gonna be a romantic setup
you can't go wrong no you can't go wrong
and I would like to see you in your date
that show please oh my date and my wife
it is your wife that Valentine's Day
what did you put on there what was that
this is caramelized walnuts in a shaving
parmesan so yeah we have it it's fresh
it's nice it's clean it's very Italian
and we're gonna have an additional that
we're gonna have all in our part of a
science this fall menu so you guys can
have other things too and we have three
thousand three thousand titles of a wine
you know a wine cellar so we can
actually get a good good one yeah good
buzz on Valentine's Day good wine to
grow with great food chef Carl has a
wrap up what's the website to make
reservations it's www lemon
shallowlv.com it's a treat to have you
in the kitchen thank you so much for
joining us